[Music]
welcome back to cbs saturday morning in
the coming decades rising sea levels due
to climate change could dramatically
impact the east and west coast of the
united states you might think another
stretch of shore the 10 000 miles of
coastline along the five great lakes is
better protected from such effects but
as ben tracy reports from marquette
michigan no place is truly untouched by
our changing climate
not going to beat
mother nature
this is
really
an example of the fourth
of the lake dennis stakowitz has lived
along lake superior for two decades
i mean this kind of looks like it got
bombed out it does
it does and even in this now long-term
relationship he says the lake still has
all the power
he showed us this shattered stretch of
road that used to be lakeshore boulevard
lake erosion
really got the best of it but ultimately
it failed because nature caught up with
us
is planning director for the city of
marquette home to about 20 thousand
people on michigan's upper peninsula the
city had to spend nearly 3 million
dollars rebuilding the road 300 feet
away from its increasingly unpredictable
neighbor
we're watching
the intensity of these storms just get
worse and worse to the point that
they're really becoming dangerous for
our infrastructure and the health and
welfare of the community so you're
seeing the extremes get more extreme the
extremes are getting
way more extreme
the storms fueled by climate change are
more frequent and intense they are
battering shorelines throughout the
great lakes turning roadways into rivers
and forcing homes off their once lofty
perches if we keep going on the path
we're on we don't really know where
these extremes are going to take us
melissa scanlan is director of the
center for water policy at the
university of wisconsin milwaukee she
says lake michigan hit a record low
water level in 2013 and then swung
wildly to record highs in the past few
years so it's normal for the great lakes
to rise and fall
how is that cycle changing the highs are
getting higher and the lows are getting
lower i'm most concerned about flooding
and sewage contaminating the drinking
water supply for millions of people the
city of milwaukee sits on lake michigan
and the local sewer district is now
tearing out these concrete storm water
channels built in the 1960s that can no
longer handle the intense rain events
they are restoring a more natural flow
to try to slow down the water to keep it
from flooding nearby homes and to keep
sewage from pouring into lake michigan
if the system gets overwhelmed the
city's infrastructures
aren't really built to deal with these
kind of rainfall extremes
and so
we need to figure out how to manage this
water and to adapt to the future of
course the great lakes do not lack for
water they hold 84 percent of north
america's surface fresh water supply air
temperatures in the region are predicted
to increase by up to 11 degrees by the
end of the century making those
notorious northern winters a bit more
bearable
that's why places like marquette
michigan are now seen by some as a
climate change refuge and they're
finding us and they're coming you lead
the way
stephanie jones sells real estate in
marquette where the housing market is
hot and they can't build new homes fast
enough but there are signs the locals
would prefer tourists rather than
transplants
are folks here ready to have a lot of
new neighbors
it depends on who you ask
a lot of people have that i'm here and i
want to be the last person so can we
just shut the door behind me feeling
dennis stackowitz never thought he'd see
people moving here for the weather no
i have to be honest with that after all
marquette put up a sign proudly
displaying its record snowfall of 22
feet
but given fires ravaging the western u.s
and hurricanes hitting the south this
small town might have a big future yeah
i didn't see it coming but
this is a
pretty good place to to weather the
storm for lack of a better term
for cbs saturday morning ben tracy
marquette michigan
as a former resident of northern
michigan not the upper peninsula but it
is beautiful up there the weather
extremes are incredible very cold but it
is interesting to see that this this bad
thing in our world right now of climate
change has that potential yeah
it's a very weird one and if somebody
grew up in lake erie yeah right i mean
winters can be lake effect snow
name it yeah yeah it's good that they're
working to solve the problem they
acknowledge it and they're working to
change or hopefully
flow with whatever changes they're
taking trying to address how to exactly
yeah